the camera Ren really likes candy
especially sour gummy candy so we're
gonna kind of see if we can train him we
got a call bell and a big box of candy
individual individual packets like the
ones you give away on Halloween and
they're under Christians desk and every
time Ren steps away we're going to put
one bag of candy on his desk and then
ring the bell we just pretend that it
didn't happen and then see like what his
reaction is
but if you
laughs match
so better balance on a desk but we're
not going to eventually ring the bell
and he's like it go again this mouth
should be arriving at Daniel's every
officer those should be watering every
time oh my god dude this is such a long
gun to you today we're talking about
thumbnail and what to do when you make
them it is something that we spend a lot
of time on and it is really important to
bring in new viewers to your channel so
this is just a little bit of our secret
sauce if you will to show you what makes
a great internet meal what's beginning
because we're going to make the
thumbnail for today's video
yeah and watch us to it right now one
thing we have been doing on occasion is
going to stock image website taking
those images and using them as part of
the thumbnail I see a final thumbnail do
not let me down you got it as you know
for the title of this video is how to
brainwash your friends how do we come up
with a thumbnail that tells that
particular story without seeming clicky
or click Beatty or false or fraudulent
and yet still piques your interest would
I click on that the first question on
even person or the person is or do the
Kings and then probably green and then
you can write and make right have lot on
there I'm on graphic stock right now if
we squint or eye
the thing that tops the most usually
works the best
it's not his way back how is he yeah
he's young with students but he order
he's going to pick it up me come back on
with one mail-order phase two I move the
bell on top of my face please
it's on top of my computer I'm going to
bring it to the speaker keep it safe all
it has to do together
take your positions
[Music]
you keep putting yourself at so much
death
[Music]
you know exploit there's one there's one
yes thank you but I hate it here where
they keep coming from
Oh
[Music]
the second rule of thumb nails after you
ask yourself would I click on that is is
it legible when it's the size of a
postage stamp but if it's legible and
this side that kid one pop brainwashing
yeah brain why why don't we go with the
hypnotic the hypnotic swirl pretty close
pretty close
oh this one the black and look if you
put run over the center yeah that's not
bad yeah ignore even feel like you're
looking down down a cord over them
digital whose densities we are shooting
a thumbnail in any like normal day if
friends started freaking out about
something you'd turn to film head anyway
right so it's fine so I can seem weird
remember we've had any time to make sure
that he doesn't believe it's me I'm
gonna have to leave the room caught me
out last time it wasn't me but because I
prank him a lot he thinks it's me so now
the Strobel variable is if I remove
myself from the room he will lose
control you ready
you heard that right
hold on that let you dig deep yeah here
[Music]
don't know what you're talking about man
and oh dude right there hey there you go
have a scared look it was the heat with
the team's about so right now I'm going
to get a screen shot of Ren I got the
shot about 18 19 seconds in we're gonna
move out mm-hmm I push the snapshot
button in Premiere and then you have a
template in Photoshop I do have a
template so we want to recreate all the
same assets every time correct now this
one this video we had a hell of a time
with because we didn't know what to call
it we couldn't make a thumbnail until we
figured out what we're going to call
usually when you name a video you're not
actually naming the video you're naming
the thumb yeah and then that combo gets
people to watch the video and then you
have to ensure that their expectation
has been meted to X and then there are
more to it yes entices new viewers to
subscribe wait wait wait wait don't get
crazy
back to this yeah when I first opened up
some mail this is what I got is the
previous video I'll delete the top and
bottom yellow bars we also have the logo
there so that way our current
subscribers know that paste that's our
video like to erase certain parts of the
yellow bars to make certain parts of the
image pop and death smart Michael was
the only one of the are Michael's to get
a college education is rum mom was
really disappointed about what Korean to
economics here's the run face always
duplicate oh you guys people click that
always always duplicate a layer
before you start with it duper
click when you folks with the lady
better people claim well we've got a
finished product here we do so we have
the image of Ren with swirly lines on
his eyes keep playing okay I was gone
for two hours Thank You thumbnail done
work dog I will show you it was five
minutes and then we'll showed you
yeah yeah I was
I was gone for two minutes
[Music]
we need anything in your life right now
throughout the after lunch treat a
delicious delectable after lunch treat
[Music]
with Rosalie this video is but you
brought graphics tax in spirit in the
create education initiative we wanted to
let you know good good graphics are
unlimited not stock images with over
350,000 graphics filters even more now
over there are contain sample crash but
good so click the link in the
description box below to get a free
7-day trial of correcta truck doing
something precious and share it we
created created today
[Music]